what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down today I have a special
guest and partner of the channel Colin
plume welcome to the show thank you nice
to see you nice to see you so you're the
CEO of noble gold correct yeah uh and a
few other I've uh also the founder of my
digital money which is a crypto uh
trading platform and sort of a serial
entrepreneur but today we're I think
we're going to talk mostly about
Commodities gold and other things yeah
I'm really excited for this because us
as women
so I was like this is great this is like
an improvement you know yeah well you
know what's funny a lot of people say
you know with Noble gold they always ask
like are you appealing mostly to men
but I it's a pretty big number almost 50
percent of our clients are women no way
yeah but and I don't know if it's you
know you're dealing with over time you
know our average client is you know 45
to 65 70. okay um yeah you'd be
surprised a lot of times it's the the
husband doesn't even want to talk about
it and he just says yeah I want to buy
get on the phone with my wife and then
she handles you know 95 percent of the
transaction so you know I you know maybe
it changes over time or you know I don't
know how it is but I think in general
young people
don't want to talk about finances uh as
much as as they should so why gold like
what makes gold different than you know
because I just feel like as a young
person we're constantly like spewed all
this like there's Bitcoin there's gold
so like how do you pick yeah well I
think you have to look at gold being
around for you know 5000 years it's one
of the oldest assets there's ever was
and it was you know it's the real true
currency uh is gold you know today
you're on the Euro you're on you're on
the pound you're on the dollar you know
all these currencies are just being uh
inflated into nothing
um you know during the the pandemic uh
in the U.S they expanded our money
supply by almost 18 for two years in a
row so now we have this awful inflation
that most people believe isn't going
away for a very long time and this has
happened all over the world yeah they
just inflate these currencies They Kick
the Can down the street uh so gold is
something that you just can't you can't
do that with it's you have to mine it
you have to find it in the ground
there's a limited supply of it you know
the supply Island Grows by about one one
and a quarter percent per year so it's a
true real fungible currency that uh has
been around a long time and it just has
you know know tons of different uses in
many different Industries especially
jewelry obviously that's the one that
people talk about is jewelry but it's
used in heart monitors and cell phones
and there's a lot of other uses for gold
out there I keep hearing about how do
you think the dollar and the pound are
gonna crash completely yeah I mean
that's I think that's why they're
talking about us moving on to these uh
digital currencies I think they they
want they know that eventually it is
going to come so I think the the story
that's going to come out there is that
you know now we're going to the digital
currency we're going to a new currency
uh because the dollar has lost so much
value and it's it's happening all over
the world people don't want to use the
dollar countries don't want to use the
dollar The Brick Nations are all moving
away from the dollar so it's very common
for people to not want to use a dollar
right now so I do think there will be a
transition of moving away from you know
these these kind of currencies into into
new currencies so what's the difference
because
um I think of like my dad my dad kind of
sounds like your target like the the
what you said between 45 and
70. yeah yeah that's my dad
um and he sold like his company but he
mostly did properties and then he did
Investments like what's the difference
between Investments properties yes I
mean so gold is is considered an
alternative investment
um today even though it probably
shouldn't be
um a lot of people put do you know if
they sell a company and they have a big
windfall they'll move into real estate
all they're moving to stocks and bonds
those are the the kind of traditional
ways to go but like right now for
instance if you look at real estate you
know in the US is a big big question
mark you know real estate in the U.S is
is very difficult to move and has is
we're seeing a dramatic pullback uh in
in some of the values across the country
people aren't able to sell so the the
the pro real estate is similar goal is
that there's a limited Supply if you're
buying it in a specific area you know if
you're in a city that people want to
live people will typically move there
um but also the downside of it is
liquidity right and so you know if
you're in properties right now so for
instance in the U.S there's you know all
these huge companies these Reed spot uh
massive Office Buildings all across the
country uh and actually I was in Phoenix
I toured a number of these Office
Buildings for a business I'm involved in
and there is just millions of square
feet of vacant office space that people
are never going back to they're never
going to go back to work in that
environment the way they used to so you
know there is that inherent risk of
getting into the wrong sector of real
estate and then maybe the investment is
difficult to sell and the returns are
are harder so you know that's one area
then the equity markets stocks right now
the equity markets have been really
Rocky because nobody knows where
interest rates are going to go we don't
know where inflation's going to go so
we've had a very bumpy road in in the
stock market over the last two years and
they're predicting you know the CEO
BlackRock predicts that we're going to
see interest rates in the five percent
range for the next five to ten years
that could be a very bad sign for the
equity markets because companies really
have been using this cheap money I mean
basically people have been using this
three four percent money to to kind of
keep growing their business and growing
and buying houses and if if we stay
above five percent or higher that could
really slow down that that engine of of
the economy that people want to to keep
going so you think there's going to be a
crash like do you think it'd be similar
to like 2007 2008 yeah I mean they
here's the thing right now they've
predicted that we're and I believe we're
in a recession even though that some of
the typical indicators in the U.S that
you know unemployment is still low but
if you look at the other factors out
there a lot of the jobs that people want
sixty five thousand and above those
those companies are not hiring we've
seen a general slowdown of the economy
in many different sectors GDP is very
low so I think unless we see some kind
of Black Swan event next year we're
going to be in a lot of trouble and in
this country and they're going to have
to keep interest rates really high and
so that's going to keep this slowdown of
the economy happening so I think it's
going to be very sluggish for many years
and then you know just looking at
inflation I don't know you know what
you're buying day to day or what you're
looking at but it just seems like it's
out of control yeah it's yeah I mean gas
prices here in the U.S you know we're
looking at six seven dollars a gallon
whereas if you go back five to seven
years ago we're in the two to three
dollar range so how do people afford to
go on a vacation or get to work or to do
all the things that they used to be able
to do when their salaries have not
doubled yet the the cost of gasoline and
all these day-to-day things have gone up
significantly food costs have gone up 20
to 30 percent energy costs the same
thing so to go back to what you're
saying about gold the reason people like
gold is because it's an asset that they
can hold you know these are assets that
we ship to people they can actually hold
these assets it has a limited Supply out
there and if you look at today's prices
it's very very affordable relative to
where a lot of people think the price of
gold and silver can go is gold typical
more of like a long-term investment
because that because I think of like if
I get a paycheck right and it's you know
let's just say it's five thousand
dollars right are you able to put that
into gold and still spend the gold or is
it more something you put away and like
leave there for a long time yeah I mean
I you can there are states here in the
U.S that are accepting gold for taxes
and payments like Utah and the state of
Texas is actually trying to pass a law
where they'll have a gold back currency
so there are places that do accept some
gold and silver but typically this is
kind of a sleepy investment it's it's
one of those Investments that you buy
and you hold for you know 5 10 15 years
and you want to just buy it and just
sort of forget about it and over time it
will go up uh it's not in this kind of
investment it's not a kind of an
investment that you're looking to trade
quickly other Investments are
investments that you want to be more
active with but when you're buying gold
it's you have a chunk of money you want
it to be you know a good hedge against
inflation you're looking at you know
kind of an insurance policy kind of buy
so it's typically a safer long-term
investment but yeah absolutely if you
have a paycheck and
you want to allocate some of it's a goal
people do that but as I said typically
our buyers you know 45 to 75 they've you
know built their nest egg and they're
trying to just they just carve off a
piece they pull some of it out of the
stock market and they just want to get
into something that's a little safer
okay so it's typically more of like a
long-term investment yeah that's
typically I mean you can see quicker
gains and if you need the money you can
always sell it you don't have to stay in
it you're not locked into it in any way
but yeah typically if I you're looking
at a five to ten year hold is is what
you should be considering when you're
buying this investment and you said you
have like a Bitcoin Trading Company too
yeah my digital money is our is our
crypto trading platform
um so for anyone that wants to get into
crypto you can do it in your IRA and you
know we were talking about you know the
thing about crypto that's hard sometimes
is that people don't you know they don't
want to remember a code or they don't
want to have their own wallet and they
don't do all they said they lose their
wallets there's the famous guy I think
he's somewhere in Europe he actually
lost the big coin and then he was trying
to find it in the land do you know the
story I've heard it I've heard I lost my
I lost my hundred dollar coin thing I
got at the convention and I that hurt my
soul a little bit
and money you know yeah and they were
you know they were probably thinking
like if we give this 100 Bitcoin out to
like a hundred people 85 are gonna lose
and we're never gonna have to pay out on
this code because you know we're not set
up anymore to to be able to you know
just have a code and just have it all
set up so my digital money we take care
of all that the paperwork all the IRS
reporting all the tax reporting really
for anyone yeah we do all that every
anyone in the US is looking to to get a
crypto account they don't want to deal
with any of that my our company does it
and we do that on the gold side too if
you're doing it in an IRA in Gold uh we
do all the tax reporting and everything
there for you too so it's all it's all
taken care of so would you say like
because when you get dollars or pounds
that that's inflating like crazy but you
still need to spend money day to day so
do you recommend that people get Bitcoin
to like spend day to day or keep
spending in cash like how do you
differentiate that well I would say the
major issue you with Bitcoin is is the
volatility uh yeah looking at a
situation where it's not stable enough
as a currency that you want to be using
it day to day in my opinion because
you're you're really looking at a
situation where it can move up and down
10 15 20 pretty easily and so that's not
stable enough as a currency now the
dollars and the pound are the same
they're losing you know anywhere from
five to eight percent per year but you
gotta have enough to transact and live
on so what I always say is you should
have enough in in currency to survive
day to day but everything else you
should be investing in something that
can hopefully achieve a higher return
than inflation and depending on what you
believe inflation is anywhere from five
to you know ten percent depending on
what numbers you're looking at you got
to be looking at investing and I think
you know talking to young people about
this is that they they have this sort of
uh hoarding mentality with currency and
cash and they I think they should be
sitting a lot in cash and actually even
at a young age you should be allocating
in your 20s and you should be allocating
a little bit into Investments monthly as
continuously as you can because the
earlier you start to build those habits
of setting money aside and getting
Returns the easier it gets when you
start to hit an age when you're getting
um when you're making the kind of money
that you do later on in your life you
know most people their earning potential
sort of hits their High number in 35 to
you know 45 50 range so building the
habits in the early 20s even if you're
only putting maybe 50 or 100 bucks a
month away or something to that number
later on when you're making bigger
income you've already built that habit
so you'll go from saving a hundred
dollars a month to a thousand or two
thousand whatever you can afford and
then you're able to sort of get to the
point where you can retire safely it's
so interesting because entertainment is
such a bubble where people just like get
like like it's like the opposite like
they're earning potential like ends at
30 you know yeah I mean yeah I know
that's not that's not the normal like
life cycle but I was just thinking how
it's like the opposite in entertainment
with like streams
yeah and professional athletes yeah
money when they're young and you know
it's and it's sort of a shocking you
know they get that shock like that first
good check or they're starting to earn
some money and
you know they think
excuse me that potentially that could go
on forever yeah
you know as we know we have a writer
strike actor strike like it gets it can
get tougher over time
um but yeah no there's you know those
two industries are really interesting I
actually have a lot of friends that are
agents for for professional athletes and
they always talk try to talk to them
early about investing in money and you
know they sign a five million dollar
deal and they get you know five million
and then you know two two and a half
million goes to taxes and they gotta pay
their agent and this so 5 million goes
down to
kind of like a million pretty fast and
you'd be surprised a lot of these guys
can blow a million bucks uh that's what
my dad told me he said the same thing he
was like a million isn't as much as you
think and I know like the average
person's gonna like be like ah Pearl
you're so privileged but like but I when
I when he started to break down like the
way people spend money um and how quick
they can blow it he's like a million
dollars in their 20s they'll blow it by
like 10 years oh easily yeah I mean you
hear about some of these athletes uh
there's you know famous like Mike Tyson
for instance uh the boxer he he earnings
300 million and when he went to jail the
second or third time he was almost
completely uh broke he blew 300 million
unwaggers
cars and you know I mean listen he lives
it up I can tell you that right now I
was having a fun life I mean the stories
that I've heard are pretty uh pretty
elaborate and and uh he definitely lived
for the moment
um but yeah when you when you make 300
million in in career earnings in boxing
you should be okay but somehow you know
he's got a tattoo on his face and he
came out and he's got a sense of humor
and now he's he's built a whole other
career but it's unusual usually people
can uh but he he was somehow able to
reinvent himself and and you know become
a a star and use this celebrity in a way
to make money yeah it's so interesting
because I'll see I'll see people like
online and my my dad's um he's kind of I
call him like the cheapest like
successful guy you'll ever meet he's
very cheap Guy and um and I'll be like
Dad how do they afford this and he'll
always tell me they can't they do not
yeah they can't afford it yeah yeah
there's a famous comedian uh Sebastian
maniscalpa who does this he has a skit
and he does like um he talks about when
his dad walks around his house he has to
tell him the parent price because like
his dad can't believe how much
everything costs basically he's like
it'll be like you know what's that TV
and he'll lie to him tell him it's like
200 and his dad is like 200 for a TV
what do you mean that sounds just like
my dad yeah that's and that's true like
you can't tell your parents the real
price of anything nowadays because
they're mine absolutely blown
um so it's it's it's funny
um I know we were sort of we broached
the subject had been and being you're
out in the UK
but one of the biggest uh you know
people always talking about central
banks buying gold one of the biggest
reported blunders uh for gold was uh
from 99 to 2001 Great Britain sold
basically 90 percent of its gold
reserves and it's sort of a blunder and
at the time I think it was interesting
because gold had sat pretty dormant from
1983-84 to 2000 it didn't really move
and so they had all this gold you know
obviously Great Britain has tons of gold
and you know they were always having
this goal and they thought it was safe
and they you know held it and then
basically they started selling it in
2001 and then within six months of them
selling it gold started to go up 20 per
year for like nine years or well eight
years in a row so it was sort of
reported one of the the biggest uh
blunders from a prime minister
um yeah and then over time I'm sorry who
was that who did it Brown I think was
the prime minister at the time I don't
know maybe you know more than me but uh
but yeah it's it's interesting
um that that sale happened and just you
know obviously horrible timing uh and it
shows you can't really predict the
market too much and if you have a stable
asset in your reserves it's probably
good to keep it and now central banks
have been buying like crazy the last two
years China Russia uh you know Brazil
you go down the list these countries are
buying tons and tons of gold and they're
putting it away because of exactly what
we talked about earlier
they don't have faith in the dollar they
don't have faith in the Euro they don't
have faith in any kind of paper
currencies and so they're divesting
getting out of U.S bonds getting out a
lot of that money trap that they've been
in for a long time and they're going
into you know the yellow metal to
protect themselves
um so it's it's a unique time in our
history I think you know you look at
what's been happening globally and and
you know overall fear of the economy and
things that are happening and people are
fleeing some of the traditional real
estate and stocks and bonds and they're
diving into uh into the L metal uh to
protect themselves okay so you said the
the stock market is a casino and it's
too risky to invest in well I I think it
depends on your risk level I think I
think a lot of people are
you know depending on where they're at
in their retirement Journey or whether
how close they are I think you have to
be cautious especially right now because
there's so many negative factors the
stock market in my opinion has really a
lot of it's been built on low cheap
money that companies in the ability to
use to grow and if we are going to have
interest rates stay in the five to seven
percent range U.S mortgages uh yesterday
hit the highest it's been in almost 23
years and 7.4 so that means that you
know two years ago a U.S homeowner could
have got a mortgage at three percent
some lower
that same mortgage on the same house
people were buying today is 85 percent
higher wow so I just think right now and
there's so many companies across the
country that are that are predicated
upon the real estate market continue to
move and people buying houses and so I
just believe that right now until we
figure out what we're going to do with
inflation until we get rates in a more
normal pattern where we get them down
maybe they don't go back to three but
they go maybe in the four or four and a
half percent range until those things
happen I think the stock market and and
real estate are going to be pretty Rocky
do you think that they'll ever go back
to the gold standard for currency it's
interesting yeah I mean I I think
hard to go to a full-backed uh gold
standard but in some ways it'd be so
great you know we just had a potential
government shutdown uh you know a few
days ago and it was averted over a
Weekend Deal over you know teen crumpets
or whatever they're eating and it's like
you have these situations where you know
the government has has
no real sense of how to balance a budget
I mean in the US it's it's literally
every year they're raising or debt
selling now we're at third the US is at
33 trillion dollars in debt
um that number is just it's it's
mind-boggling and so and because they
don't have any real recourse to to
to stop it like because we're the
world's Reserve currency it's just it's
just a matter of time before we get to
40 trillion if 50 trillion it's never
going to count whereas if we had a
partially gold-backed system we wouldn't
be able to spend this freely because
there'd have to be enough gold to back
uh all the currency out there they
wouldn't just be able to spend and
increase the money supply this much so
in a lot of ways it would be fantastic
you know the brick countries have been
talking about doing a gold back system
China's been talking about it they've
been buying a lot of gold whoever can do
it whoever Nails it I think that
currency will will become the number one
currency in the world
um but it's it's really just a matter of
politicians loving to just spend freely
and and putting them on a gold standard
does not allow them to do that you're
saying that debt is just going to keep
going up and up and up
what do you think about
and I've just heard this but I don't
really understand it completely they
talk about how it's like we're turning
into more of like a debt economy
like where businesses are even in debt
like everybody's in debt yeah yeah well
you look at like you know you hear about
these IPOs and these companies that
people sell on the stock exchange and
you're like oh my God these companies
they you know they came out on the stock
and they're so successful but 95 of
those IPOs those companies are not
profitable and they're literally just
living on debt now they're getting debt
from different places they may be
getting debt of you know getting actual
loans they may be getting money from
um VC money so you know a big
conglomerate comes on and gives them
money but and they're getting Equity
Equity money that they're getting from
different places but if you look at
these companies that they they come out
and the stock prices hit these crazy
stock prices 95 of them are actually not
profitable and so yeah we are living in
a debt Society if Assa if a company hits
a stock market uh like uber for instance
uh maybe they've hit profitability now
but over the last you know 10 years
they've never been profitable they've
literally just been getting more money
from Equity investors over time and they
just keep getting BC money and you know
they hit the stock exchange and then
there's money because the stock exchange
but overall you look at the a lot of
these companies there's there's really
no profit
um and so as a business owner who you
know and that's the interesting thing
about a small medium-sized business
small medium-sized business we're not
going to get Venture Capital Money Yeah
we actually you know maybe you get some
money from friends and family when you
start out
um you know I did it when I started
Noble gold and most of my business I
didn't but for the most part like a
small medium-sized business we have a p
l and we have to actually show profit we
have to make money in in the world so
you have these normal businesses you and
I for instance here you're a good
example too you're a business you have
to show Pro you have to make money every
month and if you don't make money every
month you're gonna have to get a loan
from somebody and who's going to want to
get a loan to to somebody that's not
profitable as at a certain point so uh
so you know I'm sure at the beginning
you had a bootstrap you're you're
putting up your own cameras you're doing
the whole thing and then you get to a
point where you hire some people and you
grow and you go from there but at the
end of the day you know small
medium-sized businesses are really the
ones that drive the economy if you think
about it because they're the ones that
actually have profit uh and when you
have profit we pay taxes you know
inspiration so so all yeah all the big
companies are just in debt and are they
going to go under is it going to kind of
be like a Sears thing where they just
eventually
it comes down to the level of debt that
a lot of these companies are in yeah
Sears obviously ran into it but if you
look at Sears they file for bankruptcy
and were able to stay open for many
years I think they filed bankruptcy
probably 20 years ago and then they were
able to stay open over time they're able
to restructure the debt they're able to
do a lot of different things uh they had
some real estate there so so they had
some some value there but yeah I mean
you do see it I mean if you go back uh
20 years and you look at you know the s
p and the Dow a lot of the companies
that were there 20 years ago are no
longer there so they do eventually they
do either fall into Oblivion or they go
out of business or stuff happens
um so you do see a shift of that wealth
happening but there's so much money made
in the VC go to IPO market and they make
their money there and they don't really
care if that company is actually
profitable it's more about just getting
it to the point where it sells out or
some bigger company buys it and then
they'll figure out if there's any any
profit uh in the company at all okay so
basically they're in debt and the
investors fund it for like 10 years or
whatever and then they sell it to a
bigger business that's what happens or
they go IPO they they go on the stock
exchange
um you know and and when they go in the
stock exchange they do interesting
things I don't know if you know about
Salesforce a big company here in the US
they they do all the CRM management but
they laid off 8 000 workers like eight
months ago because they wanted to hit
their quarterly numbers so they wanted
to hit their quote they fired you know 8
000 people and then basically after the
quarter they realized they actually
needed a lot of these people so they
were trying to hire the same people back
so they're trying to hire 3 000 of the 8
000 people back to the same company is
because they were trying to hit a
quarter they hit that quarter and then
now they want to bring those people back
because they're going to put those uh
employees back in the book so yeah it's
it's quite interesting
um when you really start to dive in the
economics of it
um and that's why for me uh always being
a big proponent of just small and
medium-sized businesses because we
really if you look at the next 10 or 15
years in the world economy you know
organizations like ours that are slowly
growing over time that actually have
profit that are doing putting jobs on
the table and have to look at you know
the actual staying profitable over time
were the companies that actually will
grow the economy uh for the future and
and that's why I think you know I'm such
a big proponent of influencers First
Amendment rights you know people like us
that are getting out hiring people and
doing the right things with business and
really trying to grow our business over
time organically should businesses put
their reserves in Gold I have had I've
had a number of Corporations uh put a
percentage in Gold
um actually the CEO of overstock.com
who's a big proponent of gold and silver
during two or three years ago he
actually had enough silver if the dollar
fell apart to actually pay his employees
in silver we've had a number of
organizations uh non-profit religious
organizations that'll put some of their
reserves into gold and silver so we've
had that happen obviously I'm not a
financial advisor I can't advise anybody
of anything but at the end of the day we
have had a lot of people do that and I
think in today's environment where you
know there's a lot of nervousness out
there I think it's worth taking a look
at gold
um because if you look historically
we're sitting in the mid 1800 range gold
did hit well over two thousand dollars
now it's 2070 so I think if if it goes
back to where it was you could see some
pretty significant upside from where it
is today
my because I think of like your target
market I think of my dad he he's very
big in like the investment like stock
market what what's like the like why
gold over Investments yeah I mean I
think like I believe that you should
have a little bit of everything so I'm
not I'm not saying you shouldn't have
any money in the stock market uh I just
think you have to understand the level
of risk and obviously there's a lot of
different ways to invest in the stock
market you can invest in international
equities you can invest in you know you
can invest in um you know the s p or the
NASDAQ different types of companies so I
I think you should be considering all of
them I I think the thing about gold that
people like when they buy gold is they
like the control you know number one you
own this so there's no
fund manager there's no
um it's not a stock you're actually
buying a real asset which I think a lot
of people when they get gold or they
have it they feel very comfortable that
they don't have to trust because in
essence anytime you buy a stock you have
to trust that team that CEO that they're
doing the right thing with the business
whereas this you're buying the asset
you're you're in control of it and a lot
of people especially as they get older
they want assets that they can actually
control and they're in charge of also
the other idea with the stock that some
people like is that you're sharing it
right you're just buying a share of a
bigger Corporation and a lot of things
can affect the value of that Corporation
you know we've seen things like you know
CEOs of company say the wrong thing get
fired and the stock price drops ten
twenty thirty percent you know you saw
what happened to Bud Light great example
somebody thought there's oh that isn't
bad yeah and and what happened that
stock one and then you'd think to
yourself
Bud Light you know Budweiser Bud Light
right that's a real horse you would
never expect them to put a gay guy on
there like
and one you know one siled person on
their marketing team said hey we want to
hit up go after a .001 demographic and
we're gonna do an ad and it blew up I
mean they're down I don't know if you
know this they're down like 25 their
business and actually Budweiser had to
sell off like 10 of their uh alcohol uh
companies you know they they have a
number of them they had to sell off 10
to kind of fight off some of the loss
that they had so you know that's the pro
that is the one major issue so Gold's
like the most consistent because all the
other like the Bitcoin goes up like and
so even though the stock market the
general trend is up and even though the
the Investments the general Trend tends
to be up gold is like the most
consistent one out of the three yeah
you're sort of betting against the other
things falling apart right you're sort
of like insurance it's it's it's a
similar idea to buying you know you're
buying some safety you're buying
something safe you're buying something
that's been around a long time and and
you know and if inflation continues to
go up and it's at the numbers that they
expect typically gold uh uh goes well
and I'd also say Platinum uh right now
is a Very undervalued Metal they're
starting to use platinum in the
catalytic converters and cars and so now
that we're moving to a lot of these
electric cars they're going to need
Platinum so I'd also look at Platinum
right now as as being an undervalued
asset platinum's just under 900 an ounce
um so yeah it's it's typically you know
goal old is typically moves kind of
inverse to a lot of the other uh markets
out there and so you have gold silver
and platinum gold silver Platinum
Palladium are the four metals that we
sell
um we sell it all in bullion you know
bully means minted and mass Supply so
these are Boolean uh gold coins these
are bullion bars anything that they emit
in Mass surprise considered bullion and
the reason that Boolean is where you
want to have the majority of it of when
you're buying precious metals is because
if a lot of people get into these you
know coins these kind of over dramatized
coins that are really expensive and not
necessary so you want to stick into
bullion coins and bars that are mass
produced because you're going to get the
most value
they're the least priced so you're going
to get the most bang for your buck when
you buy you know generic bullion coins
and bars do you mean like those those
like packets they used to sell with all
the you know what I'm talking about like
the gold coin packets or like it'd be
like silver you mean like uh like the
the bars that come in no no when I was a
kid they would always give me the it was
like a package of all these different
like coins for the year
we were going to but I wish I went there
no no my mom would get me like the the
coins for the year I don't know do you
have those I know I don't think those
are I don't know
they're not real gold and silver but if
they are you may want to chat I would
just say you should check it out and
make sure it's not a normal childhood I
don't know you might have like you know
like you know 50 Grand and golden silver
is that how much that's worth like coins
well this so give me an idea so these
are two one ounce gold coins they're
worth like ah 1950 each like like dot
like 19 like 1950 19. oh what that's
like a two grand coin
yeah yeah there's two coins here yeah
have you ever seen the videos okay this
because this just put a lot of context
have you ever seen those videos where
they ask do you want like a gold coin
you want a gold coin or do you want like
a Coca-Cola
really seen those and I I die laughing
because they always choose the Coca-Cola
over the two thousand dollar coin yeah
wow that's a really bad choice yeah yeah
and one of the videos that it's it's
actually this coin it's the Canadian
maple leaf coin you can't really see it
but
um the guy says I don't want that that's
a Canadian coin why would I want a
Canadian coin and the guy says but it's
gold and he goes no I'll just
[Laughter]
yeah it just it that's and that's what I
was saying earlier about how young
people just don't even want to think
about investing they don't even they're
scared of it uh and I think this is
honestly this generation of of younger
people is the first generation that's
probably not going to end up better than
their parents I think it's the dynamic
it's really sh
um and so because of that because they
know that it's they're a little behind
the eight ball just because of
everything that's happening in the world
they're sort of afraid to kind of ask
questions and try to and and really try
to get out from under that but also with
that for people that are willing to ask
questions and are willing to get out
there there is tremendous opportunity to
make wealth today too because I think
that for more people in their 20s that
are afraid there's obviously going to be
some opportunities for people that kind
of push through and and take a leap of
faith and start asking questions at a
young age so if I if I bought if I said
today so if I wanted five thousand
dollars of gold I'd get two coins right
two and a half get two coins yeah or or
you could do and listen these are one
ounce coins so there's you know you
could do different sizes of coins but
yeah you'd probably get this and then
you'd fill it in with some silver that's
typically what people would do you'd
fill in the rest you know the thousand
dollars left over in in silver coins you
know that are trading in the you know 27
28 range you'd fill it up there so how
like do I make money over time or does
it stay that how does it so if I had
five thousand dollars and then five
thousand go like how does it
yeah in essence you're buying power like
this is the scenario that you should
think about if you go back a hundred
years okay so you had let's say it was
it was uh 1922. uh or 1923 and you had
this gold coin a one ounce gold coin so
in the U.S gold they had 20 gold coins
called sync audits so a 20 gold coin a
hundred years ago would buy
you could go out a guy could go out and
buy a suit he could go out and buy
groceries he could buy flowers for his
wife he could take her out to dinner and
he'd still have money left over with
this one gold piece right
today 100 years later
1900 two thousand dollars could still
buy a suit still still buy groceries you
could still take your wife out to dinner
you could still buy her flowers so you
can still the buying power 100 years
later is still the same maybe more right
obviously you could buy more today with
two thousand dollars but the idea is in
five or ten years that these gold pieces
will be able to keep up with the same
standard of living whereas if you had
uh two thousand dollars in actual
dollars from even 20 years ago for
instance you know the average rent let's
just say in Los Angeles 20 years ago was
650 dollars for a one bedroom apartment
today that one bedroom apartment in Los
Angeles is going to cost you between two
thousand and twenty one hundred dollars
so if you just left your money in cash
you're not going to be able to buy you
know the same value in that one bedroom
apartment that gold piece that you
bought uh in 20 years ago in 2001 you
bought it at you know 270 280 an ounce
and now it's trading at 1900 so that
gold piece has gone up significantly
almost 10 times uh in the 20 years and
your the value of your currency your
paper money has dropped significantly so
that you can't even afford uh to live in
a one bedroom apartment so if you sit in
cash over time or any Fiat money you're
always going to lose uh over time and so
basically there's going to be this big
crash soon where the you think anyways
but the and it seems like the interest
rates are predicting so there's going to
be a crash of like the housing market
maybe Investments and not Bitcoin but if
Bitcoins like up and down every month
right yeah Bitcoin yeah Bitcoin is
interesting you know I think bitcoin's
like any investment like a
cryptocurrency that can go up 10 or 20
or 30 or 50 times you sort of have to
throw it in a different investment
category it's like very high risk your
high risk exactly you know I'd say you
put that in your higher risk so I don't
but your two different traditional safe
Investments real estate stocks and bonds
uh gold and silver I think people really
have to look at the Dynamics of what's
going to happen over the next five years
and really make sure that they're
invested in the right areas and they're
looking at safety and also not being
afraid to take some money off the table
and to get into different Investments
because I do think it's going to be
Rocky for the next you know I think for
the next five years the the markets are
going to be pretty Rocky and I think
we're going to see pretty flat growth uh
in most of the equity markets and I
think real estate is going to have a lot
of trouble too so how much in savings
should people have before they invest in
gold like how many months do you think
yeah I think you want to have at least
three months saved uh when you're
talking about it a lot of financial
advisors will tell you six months
um but I I think you know somewhere in
that range of three to six months rent
once you get to that moment
um you know you should be looking in
investing any anything above that
um you know the good thing right now
that you know obviously there's a lot of
stuff that's down but the good thing
right now is that most banks are paying
between four and five percent so you're
actually getting a little bit better
return in the banks than you were before
I mean you know you go back three years
you're making zero percent or half a
percent so that's that savings crunch of
three to six months you can actually
make a little bit of money now which is
great but anything about beyond that
um unless you're saving towards some
kind of larger investment or you're
saving towards a business you probably
want to have that working in some kind
of investment uh out there in the
markets okay so three to six months
roughly and then then you can invest in
gold so if someone wants to invest how
do they do it like what's this process
yeah if they if they call so with Noble
gold we're actually sort of gone the
opposite way of where a lot of
businesses we actually talk to people on
the phone
um we have people on the phone that you
can talk to and walk you through the
process I know everybody's gone digital
and app and all that stuff but we
believe that when you're building a
relationship and you're buying something
you know significant value you're going
to want to talk to somebody so you can
always call Noble gold Investments talk
to a live person they're going to give
you a lot of information and a no
pressure environment uh you can go to
our website at noblegoldinvestments.com
so any of those two ways is the best but
my recommendation is to call have them
send out the information ask a lot of
questions and then start to build some
rapport with somebody over the phone so
you start to get more comfortable with
it and and feel that you're you know
working with someone that you like and
then you can get a lot of your questions
answered in a in a timely manner and do
you get like your own agent almost like
like yeah you're working with you yeah
everybody has their own uh customer
service person they they work within
teams so if somebody's you know out of
town or sick or whatever there's always
a backup person to that person that you
have but yeah you're going to build a
relationship uh with somebody there and
you're gonna like you know these are
friendly people these are all people
that buy and own gold and silver so
they're not you know this is stuff that
they believe in and they own
um but yeah I think you're gonna find
that people are really nice really
interesting and and I want people to
check out our reviews I mean I know you
did before you started working with us
you know you checked us out make sure
we're okay we want people to check out
our reviews uh to make sure that you
know they see something that they like
and we we urge people to go out there
and check out about Noble gold
Investments and then
um basically then you buy the gold and
then they'll send it to you I'm just
walking I'm just walking through because
first yeah all the schools over here
that I have we can send directly to your
doorstep or if you don't want to hold it
for whatever reason we can store it in a
depository for you oh okay oh so you can
put in a deposit yeah yeah it's and it's
in a segregated account and basically
they they check it and they shrink wrap
it and then they put it on your own
shelf so it's all segregated uh so you'd
have your own gold and silver depository
if some people travel a lot or they
don't want to have in their house safety
reasons so we can do that for you all so
um but typically most people get some
gold and silver delivered to their to
their doorstep which so you should
always pick the coin not the not the
coke uh yeah I mean you could do a
little bit
it's all it's all preference have you
ever thought about doing that at like um
like for a marketing thing I think
that'd be hilarious what doing uh but do
you want the coin or the Coke and see
like on college campus
I haven't done because I I don't know if
I could hold a straight face frankly if
I interviewed someone and I had a gold
coin worth 1900 and I had a Coca-Cola
and they didn't take the I think I would
be mad I think actually I'd probably get
mad at them and so that's why
I'm not that route so so what are the
most important things for investors to
keep in mind well I think with any
investment there's obviously risk so you
have to look at everything there's some
level of risk in every investment that
you're going to get into
um so you have to keep that in mind and
I also think you have to know what kind
of investor you are there's investors
that that love risk I'm a more risk
adverse I'm I'm willing to take as an
entrepreneur I'm willing to take on some
more risks so I have some things that
are I'm doing risk here things like
Bitcoin and crypto uh and then I have
other things that I just want really
safe and I and that being said all the
things that we talked about stocks and
real estate I own all of those things
too but I as time goes on and as things
shift in the year that I'm investing and
I'm putting money out there I look at
what I think the best opportunity is for
the next three to five years and so I
think ideally what you have to do is you
have to understand what kind of investor
you are and then I think the number one
thing you have to do is really spend
some time educating yourself and reading
and not thinking that somebody else is
going to do it for you because the days
of people working in a company for 40
years and they have they have a
retirement or a pension or whatever and
that's gonna you're just gonna ride off
into the sunset and everything's gonna
be fine uh those days are are long gone
people are living and it's not because
companies don't want to do it it's just
that people are living you know the
average age was 71 you know 70.
30 years ago now we're talking about 100
105 110. I mean nobody could calculate
an extra 35 years of living uh into a
retirement plan so I think you have to
not be afraid to take the bull by the
horns and really get out there and start
diving into some information and
learning about what's available is that
common people are living
people born today are gonna live to to a
hundred I I hope not that's like that's
like so hard
a long time
mistakes you see investors make
um I think the biggest mistakes
investors make
is
well I think people that invest in gold
the biggest mistake is that they fall
victim to the uh too good to be true
scams there's a lot of companies out
there in our space that are offering
free five thousand or ten thousand
dollars in silver and gold and people
think it's actually free
um nothing is free in business there's
no freebies you know if we offer one
coin for you know two to three hundred
dollars that that is legit but a company
is offering ten thousand dollars in free
silver it's like what's the what's the
hook here and it's because those
companies can charge you know 30 40 50.
I've even seen 60 commissions so I think
the biggest mistakes is that people fall
victim to these free scams and you
really have to be careful uh about doing
it and it also goes back to what I was
saying earlier the biggest mistakes
people fall for is that they think
people are going to do it for them you
have to ask questions even if you hire a
financial advisor you have to question
them you know every year every quarter
you know what's going on what is this
fee what's happening here you can't be
afraid to go in and ask those questions
and so I think the biggest mistake
people make is that they they don't ask
questions and they're not aggressive
with their with their finances so how do
you vet a financial advisor how do I
battle a financial no not battle vet how
do you vet oh oh um well I I think like
seeing your track record you know
someone that's had a 10 or 15 year track
record and seeing that the returns that
they've had getting some ideas of where
they think the future is going to go
um learning about their feet I think the
fee structure a lot of times people
don't realize that there's Financial
drivers that'll charge one one and a
quarter one and a half percent but then
on top of that if they're recommending
mutual funds the mutual funds can have
two to three percent in fees in there
too so you're talking about in some
worst case scenarios you can have three
to five percent of an annual return just
taken off the table
so I think those are things you got to
really dive into there's financial
advisors that just charge a one-time
flat fee and they'll you know you'll pay
them four or five hundred dollars and
they'll go okay here's where you should
go for the next five years so that might
be a better fit
um but really diving into the fee
structure and then looking at past
performance I think is your your best
gauge and especially over the last two
to three years if you have a financial
that had any kind of decent return
um then you know they've probably done
pretty well overall because the last two
to three years have been really uh
difficult in the markets isn't that like
aren't they not allowed to show their
clients finances though so how do you
know but they can show they can show the
returns of the different uh Investments
that they've been in that they've chosen
yes you're right okay I was like yeah
but they'll take it they'll take a a
portfolio of someone that they invested
they could show the different assets
that are in there and then they can show
that and put that in front of you but
yeah you're 100 right now they can't
obviously show your uh portfolio and
there's you know privacy laws against
that so what's a normal like percentage
that for if you said the percentage
mutual fund fee yeah I mean they're what
what kind of returns I think the returns
that people are looking for today I
think you got to be making overtime you
want to try to hit close to 10 over time
that's like a typical that's the number
that you really need to hit because if
you think inflation right now is five to
six maybe seven percent if you're not
hitting 10 after all the fees you're
probably not in a profit zone so that's
I think that's the number that they've
that they try to hit and if you look at
the stock market over time it has hit
that many of the years
um but I do believe where an unusual
time so I don't know if we're going to
be continue to hit those returns for the
next three to five years but yeah you're
looking at a 10 as a number that most
people want to hit that would be the
goal and what's like a bad one what's
like a don't average wow yeah there's I
think anything that you're looking
that's in the one to three percent range
uh unless
you're just in strict preservation mode
and you're like you know near the end of
your life and you're just trying to make
sure that you don't lose money
um that's a totally different strategy
but for someone young like you or
someone that's in the growth for me you
know I want to hit that 10 to 12 Number
yearly if possible because I know that
those are the numbers that I need to hit
because there are going to be years that
I'm going to be down uh you know be
negative five to ten percent you know if
you go back in you know 2001 there were
some pretty negative years uh 2022 so
you need those 10 to 12 numbers in the
positive years to make a for the the
negative years that you're gonna have in
a you know 20 to 40 year lifespan of
investing well thank you for coming on
the channel today I feel like I learned
a lot girl thank you I appreciate you uh
you having me on and it was fun and uh
hopefully we'll do it again uh very soon
yeah I think it'd be an interesting
series to like have like a finance
person talking about it yeah
obviously you've done your homework so I
appreciate that if anyone wants to dive
into Noble gold Investments they can
check out our website or call us at
877-646-5347 all right guys
um make sure you like the video on your
way out give him a call today subscribe
to the channel and I'll talk to you next
time